new at six o'clock it's National HIV
testing day and the Southern Nevada
Health District is urging people to get
tested they say positive HIV numbers
still high in southern Nevada but the
first step is to stop the spread and
knowing if you have it a news now
reporter Victoria Saha takes us inside
one of their mobile clinics to show the
process of testing
day eight mobile clinics were spread
throughout the valley for anyone needing
to get tested or simply come by to get
information the CDC recommends that
everyone everyone at least once in their
lifetime be tested for HIV so we want
every single person in our community to
come out according to the U.S Department
of Health and Human Services about 1.2
million people in the U.S are HIV
positive about 13 percent of them don't
know they have it the latest data from
2021 shows 441 people in Clark County
were diagnosed with the sexually
transmitted disease there's been many
advancements when it comes to treating
it someone is diagnosed as HIV positive
we will help them to get on
antiretroviral therapy which is
medication they will take it every
single day which would make their viral
load become so low that it is
undetectable so their sexual partners
will not get it nor their babies even if
you miss getting tested today the
Southern Nevada Health District offers
free HIV testing on a regular basis at
their Clinic it's a test similar to this
one you can get your results back within
60 seconds and it's free Victoria Saha 8
News Now